sera posée par monsieur bernard gérard
le groupe l'est républicain
madame la présidente de mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse
s'adresser à monsieur le premier
ministre le gouvernement a fait voter la
loi du 13 octobre 2014 sur je cite
l'avenir de l'agriculture
depuis sous votre gouvernement les
agriculteurs ne se voit plus d'avenir
vous avez fait voter la loi du 15 ou
2014 renforçant je cite l'efficacité des
sanctions pénales depuis avec votre
garde des sceaux les français n'ose plus
sortir de chez eux et les détenus se
promène dans les rues
vous avez fait voter la loi du 16 mars
2015 pour des communes je cite forte et
vivante
depuis les communes sous votre
gouvernement n'ont plus ni force ni
moyens
la liste pourrait être longue de ces
lois au titre ronflant dont certaines
portent sur la croissance et l'emploi
dont on connaît les chiffres calamiteux
où sûr je cite la reconquête de
l'économie réelle
sans doute pour vous inciter à
redescendre sur terre les français ne
vous croit plus mais un de vous nos
outils tas de vos nouveaux titres heures
vient de nous préparer un projet de loi
pour une république numérique
rien de moins que cela ce projet est en
phase de consultation citoyenne avec je
suppose comme ligne de force
l'égalité d'accès à internet entre tous
nos concitoyens une république numérique
nécessite d'abord quand tous lieux du
territoire national chacun de nos
concitoyens puissent avoir un égal accès
haut débit
or une grande partie de nos territoires
notamment ruraux sont en totale carence
en la matière j'en prends pour exemple
la métropole de lille 24 de ses 85
communes ont aujourd'hui des carences en
adsl je ne parle même pas de la fibre
optique la république numérique madame
la ministre est elle un nouveau m'irrite
mirage
comment allez vous aider nos territoires
nos communes dans leurs relations avec
les opérateurs et quelles sont vos
propositions concrètes et financières
pour réduire la fracture numérique
si le sujet rare la parole est à même la
secrétaire d'état chargée du numérique
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
alors je ne sais pas si parler de
république numérique c'est utiliser un
titre ronflant je crois que sept en tout
cas actualiser un logiciel républicain
fondé sur la liberté l'égalité et la
fraternité pour préparer l'avenir de
notre pays à la révolution numérique et
pour cela est bien le dernier volet
c'est effectivement la fraternité qui
dit fraternité dit inclusion dit
accessibilité et inclusion en
particulier des territoires qu'ils
soient urbains ou ruraux c'est la raison
pour laquelle le président de la
république a lancé dès 2012 appelant
france très haut débit sans précédent y
compris par ses financements publics 3
milliards et demi d'euros consacrés au
déploiement numérique dans les
territoires pour les zones rurales et
périurbaines c'est le double c'est le
double du montant des financements qui
était réservé aux mêmes objectifs sous
la majorité précédente
très concrètement nous assurons la
signature de conventions pour les zones
denses démographiquement c'est à dire
les grandes villes avec les opérateurs
privés et c'est le cas en particulier
pour la métropole lilloise
malheureusement la fusion entre sfr et
numericable a fait prendre du retard
dans le déploiement à lille et c'est la
raison pour laquelle le gouvernement
vote sera très ferme en exigeant des
opérateurs qu'ils remplissent leurs
engagements qui figurent dans des
conventions signées à la demande de
l'état sur les territoires ruraux
le plan de la région du nord pas de
calais est l'un des plans les plus
ambitieux pour notre pays qui devra
faire de la france le pays le plus
connecté d'europe d'ici dix ans si
madame la ministre
la séance des questions au gouvernement
est terminée
la séance est suspendue